Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie.
This would be my new Marvel video.
They just announced that they're canceling
Comic-Con this year.
There's going to be no big panel.
They were planning on
showing off a bunch of trailers,
So I'll explain what we were going to get
and what their plans are now like
when they're going
to be giving us those trailers instead
and how It's a big opportunity
now for James Gunn and DC.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I will do Comic-Con videos.
There'll be other trailers dropping,
like there'll be a bunch of DC stuff
happening there.
Don't worry, because James Gunn
will be taking that opportunity.
The power vacuum left by Marvel's absence
to show off something really cool,
they'll be revealing who the next Superman
is, or at least pretty good chance.
That's
basically what they've been waiting on.
they've already pretty much found out
who that next Superman is going to be.
All explained later in the video.
Since this is mostly about Marvel stuff.
the big news, though,
is that Marvel canceled their plans.
The reason why they did
this isn't totally
because of Jonathan Majors,
although a lot of people are like,
wait a minute is because of
what's going on with him
because he is a big part of their plans.
Have Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty.
It seemed like he was going to be
a big part of Avengers six Secret Wars.
They definitely had to make
some adjustments because of that.
There's reportedly been some changes
to the way they end Loki Season two
because he's in a lot of the episodes as
Viktor Timeline Kang another Kang variant.
but because nobody knows how
the trial with him is going to go down.
They've just made adjustments
to account for whatever
might wind up happening, either
good or bad, we won't really find out
what Marvel is going to be doing with him
until after Loki Season two comes out.
Basically,
the end of Loki will completely explain
that the
real reason why Marvel canceled Comic-Con
this year is because of the strikes
there's a writers strike
that's been going on for a while
now You probably heard that's why they've
been delaying all the Marvel movies.
They just delayed Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty and Secret Wars.
But there's also an actors strike.
The actors union is about to go on strike
and it would happen around the time
Comic-Con is happening.
Meaning none of the actors would show up
to promote the trailers at Marvel
Comic-Con panel
like you normally see every summer.
Like Kevin. Foggy
last year brought all the actors out.
They promoted all the Marvel Phase five
stuff, the Disney Plus series, the movies.
So even though they're not doing that,
they will have a presence
on the show floor.
But what they're talking about
there is actually Marvel Comics
doing their regular booth.
They typically do that every year.
They've been doing that ever since
Marvel Studios
started promoting their movies,
kind of Marvel Studios
at their whole age stuff.
And then Marvel Comics
did their show for stuff.
what they'll wind up doing, though, is it
both strikes
have ended by later this year
and hopefully they do.
Hopefully the studio's come
to an arrangement with all of them.
is it closer to D23 and then later Disney
Plus DE they'll do their own events,
which they already kind of do
every year on top of Comic-Con.
Even if they do go to Comic-Con, now.
They'll just use those
as their big trailer fest,
where they show previews trailers
for the upcoming shows and movies.
They did something similar
during the virus when Comic-Con
had to shut down the in-person
live event part of the convention.
So none of the studios had any big mega
panels.
Marvel DC just held their own separate
events like DC did their DC
Fandome events.
Marvel was planning on showing off
like the big trailers, all the big panels
they were planning on doing before
all the strikes and their cancellations.
They were going to do
a big preview of Daredevil Born Again
Charlie Cox and Vincent D'Onofrio
had been doing a bunch of conventions
recently.
This is that they were also going
to be at Comic-Con
doing a bunch of Daredevil
born again stuff.
Oh, sorry.
Well, I think that.
I think you.
You. Aren't
you supposed to talk about my show or
what?
Your show.
I think you mean my show.
the early trailer
that they would have shown off for that
probably would not have been made public
just because they're still
so early in the filming.
And there's a couple other things
that they want to promote
before that that are coming out.
they even had to make a couple of delays
in the Daredevil Born Again
episodes recently.
And I think that they just indefinitely
delayed it because they ran up against
all the episodes
that they've already written.
And the writers have been on strike,
so they can't write any more episodes,
so they can't create any more material
to film.
Marvel was going to show off
an echo trailer, the star of that series,
who's coming back from Hawkeye.
So we're going to be at Comic-Con
showing off those episodes.
Remember,
they just announced that they're going
to be releasing those in November around
when the Marvel's movie is coming out,
But they're releasing It Binged style,
which is a huge change for Marvel
the main reason for that is, one
they're not super confident in.
It is being as popular
as something like Loki
just because there's
relatively low interest in the character
compared to the other main characters
like the other usual characters, you would
expect to see a big series like that.
it also they're in a weird situation
because they just delayed
all their Marvel movies
and Disney Plus series.
They started to stretch the schedule out
the way that they released things,
mostly for financial reasons,
like they're hurting for money,
so they want to stretch their content out
as much as possible.
but because they're doing that,
they're developing this backlog.
So they have a bunch of shows
just sitting on a shelf
waiting to be released
that they've been holding.
the longer this goes on,
the bigger that backlog is, the faster
they want to get stuff out.
in at the end of the year,
there's reportedly a bunch of big stuff
coming out.
So Marvel just wants to get it out
the door as quickly as possible.
And if they didn't think
it was going to be super popular,
they just going to release it all at once
and say, here you go, just enjoy it.
Everybody watch it all. Have fun. buy.
All reports of people
that have seen early footage.
It seems like it'll be solid.
Marvel just isn't sure that it's
going to be quite the banger, they say.
Like Loki, Season two is going to be
they have also shown off another trailer
for the Marvel's movie Captain Marvel two.
That's their next big movie
coming in November.
Comic-Con is primarily for them
to promote their movies
and it's connected to Secret Invasion.
What's happening with Nick Fury?
The Skrulls will lead into that.
I just started doing Secret Invasion
episodes while link my episode one video
at the end of this,
The other really big thing is
they would have announced their fantastic
Four movie cast.
And arguably, I think this would have been
the more talked about thing.
they've been auditioning and meeting with
people for the most part for a while now.
There've been a lot of cast members
everyone believe were their final picks
before the strike.
that could change because of the strike,
because scheduled
start to become a problem
if there are too many delays
in getting things started.
But reportedly
it was Adam Driver as Reed Richards, Mr.
Fantastic Margot Robbie
as the new Sue Storm Invisible Woman.
Paul Mescal is Johnny Storm a.k.a Human
Torch and Daveed Diggs as Ben Grimm.
The thing I've already got a couple of
Fantastic four videos for that new movies.
All link them in the description below,
their ending in the middle of filming.
Deadpool three.
Ryan Reynolds would have done some funny
non trailer promo type of joke
with Hugh Jackman.
Again,
kind of like the last show they released
where they were just messing around
promoting the fact that they were doing
Deadpool three together,
Hi. Hi.
How are you?
You have questions? Yes,
I had a lot of questions.
I'm sure you had a lot of questions.
But rest assured,
we're going to answer them right now.
Like, for example, how is Wolverine alive?
Yeah.
After Logan, Logan takes place in 2029.
Totally separate thing.
Logan died in Logan. Not touching that.
What actually happens be
they're going to be so many of the classic
X-Men coming back from the X-Men films
that it's going to be a lot of fun.
all the other upcoming Marvel series
and movies, they would have just waited
till D23 and Disney Plus day
to release trailers for it no matter what.
So now they're basically just doing
everything later this year at D23 and
Disney Plus DE Before that happens though,
there will be a lot of Ahsoka trailers
because that's the next big Disney
Plus series coming from Star Wars.
There'll be some Loki season two trailer
that they're not going to
wait till after Loki Season two to release
Loki Season two trailers.
but everybody's now
realizing this presents a huge opportunity
for James Gunn
to promote his new DCU projects
that Blue Beetle coming out in August,
even though he wasn't really responsible
for that, did say that Blue Beetle
would be one of the first characters
that's Canon to his DCU.
there's still Aquaman two.
They still need to promote that.
So he'll probably talk
a little bit about that.
But like I said,
the big deal is announcing
who the next Superman is going to be.
James
Gunn said that they were pretty much done,
maybe not totally done,
but pretty much done
with all the auditions,
and they pretty much selected
who they thought that it was going to be.
but they were going through some due
diligence steps
and letting the CEO of the company
sort of weigh in on their decision.
But per James Gunn's new contract,
he can basically say
who the new Superman is going to be
without needing approval from the CEO.
So it's more of a courtesy
that he's doing that
there've been a lot of names
in the last month.
David Corenswet definitely
seemed like one of the people's top picks.
He definitely looks the part.
He even kind of looks like he could be
Henry
Cavill's younger brother in real life.
And To me, it's not about the notoriety.
It's about the craft.
It's about showing up to work every day,
you know, And for a super,
that can be surreal. What?
In many ways,
we contribute to the reality of the scene,
even more so than the principal actors.
But hey, I've got a casting tomorrow, and
if they pick me, that's $10 in my pocket.
Did exactly what we're doing now.
They're going through tons and tons of
actors to see who captures that spirit.
The thing they don't talk about much.
When they talk about Chris Reed,
they talk about his pureness,
his hope, his goodness.
They talk about,
you know, the way that he plays
Clark as being so different from the way
he plays Superman
and how he can turn that on in an instant.
like Frisky
now. But there's this playfulness
about Superman, this
when he's saving a cat, he's got that
wry smile And that is one of the best
parts of the movie,
is the playfulness of Superman.
He enjoys what he's doing.
He likes helping human beings and like.
it definitely sounds like
he understands the Superman character.
But you can let me know in the comments
who you want to play.
The new version of Superman.
either way, set your clocks.
They're probably going to announce
that at their big Comic-Con panel
the big takeaway, though, is that Marvel's
loss is James Gunn's game, like it's
his opportunity to just blow
everybody's minds
and get them really excited
for his new DCU projects
So let me know what you want to see
from James Gunn and DC at Comic-Con
Now that they basically don't
really have competition, so to speak.
there'll be stuff happening.
Like Sony will have a panel.
They could show off
some more kraven the Hunter footage
because that's coming in October.
make all the kraven time jokes
that you want is kraven time
the funny thing about that
is that his origin story in the trailer
is actually a lot like almost
like they borrowed, quote unquote
borrowed from Cat man's origin story
in the DC Universe.
it almost looks like a copy paste
situation.
don't worry, though,
even though Marvel is going to be dropping
a whole bunch of trailers,
there will still be Loki.
Season two trailer is coming real soon.
While we have a bunch of secret invasion
stuff happening,
they'll mostly be promoting
the Asoka episodes that are coming up too.
click.
Here for my full Marvel's Secret Invasion
Episode one video and Easter Eggs
and click here for that flash alternate
ending a bunch of Superman deleted scenes
in the alternate Post-Credits
scene with the Justice League.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!